-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, after spending
four days in the hospital,
last night,
President Trump arrived
back at the White House
and it was quite a scene.
Take a look.
-Walking out the doors
of Walter Reed,
boarding Marine One for his
flight back to the White House,
where he marched up the steps.
-And then, the president,
who is still contagious,
did something remarkable.
He took off his mask.
And the president,
who is supposed
to be in isolation,
then walked inside
to a room full of people.
[ Laughter ]
-Pssh!
-There's a lot to unpack here.
First, why would he use
the White House entrance
with the most stairs?
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
I've never seen him climb
those steps in four years.
I mean, why would he
do that now?
The Obamas were in perfect shape
and they never climbed
those steps.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, I'm not sure
it was safe for him
to climb 22 steps before COVID.
[ Laughter ]
It felt like that famous scene
where Rocky climbs up the steps,
but everyone behind him
is running
in the opposite direction.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Bene womp! ♪
♪ Buna -- fleneh wah ♪
I'm trying to do the reverse --
-The reverse of an A chord?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clapping ]
♪ Wanah wonk ♪
-No, no.
-No?
-1.8 million, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Good for him.
He made it to the top,
where he was greeted
by some staffers
showing off their best,
"Oh, my God.
We're so glad you're back" face.
[ Laughter ]
Then, the big reveal
atop the balcony,
he took off his mask
and you could almost hear
him being like...
[ As Trump ]
Ta-da!
And, now, for my next trick,
I will make everyone
in the White House disappear.
[ Laughter ]
Trump pulled off that mask
like he was revealing
that he'd been his
twin brother the whole time.
[ Changes accent ]
You fools, it was me, Ronald!
[ Laughter ]
The entire time.
That's the craziest thing
he's ever done on that balcony,
and that's the same place
where he looked
straight into an eclipse.
[ Laughter ]
If you're worried Trump didn't
use that mask again, don't be.
He then used it
to turn every doorknob.
[ As Trump ]
Safety first.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you close it.
-Ew!
-When he got back
to the White House,
Trump tweeted a video
where he once again
downplayed the virus.
Listen to this.
-I just left
Walter Reed Medical Center
and it's really
something very special.
And I learned so much
about coronavirus
and one thing that's
for certain --
don't let it dominate you.
Don't be afraid of it.
You're going to beat it.
And I know there's a risk,
there's a danger,
but that's okay.
And, now, I'm better
and maybe I'm immune.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
I don't know.
Maybe I'm Spider-Man.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe I have Spidey powers
and I can climb
up the White House.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like that part
of the movie
where Trump was bitten
by a werewolf
and plays it off like it's
no big deal. He's like --
[ As Trump ]
Totally fine.
Never better.
Sure, I howl at the Moon
and I have a taste for humans,
but, mostly, a-okay.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's still sick and he thinks
he's immune. He's like --
[ As Trump ]
I just tested negative.
I just peed on a nasal swab
five minutes ago, so.
[ Laughter ]
Could we look into that?
Also, I'm pretty sure Trump
has become our first
vlogger-in-chief.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
What's up, fam?
It's your boy DJ T.
[ Laughter ]
Just got out of the hospital.
Feeling hundo p.
Be sure to like and subscribe
and check out my merch.
[ Laughter ]
Well, after all that, Trump is
back in the White House,
but it's a very
different White House
than the one he left just a few
days ago. Watch this.
Yeah, Trump staffers want
to work somewhere safer,
so they all booked tickets
for a Carnival cruise.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the White House
is practically empty.
Things are so bad,
today Trump had to write
a tell-all book about himself.
[ Laughter ]
It is not a great scene
over there.
Tonight Trump was
outside Melania's door,
whispering
through the keyhole...
[ As Trump ]
♪ Do you want to build
a snowman? ♪
[ Laughter ]
But the White House is
taking some precautions.
For example, the press briefing
room was thoroughly sanitized.
Take a look at this.
There you go, yep.
Later, that same guy was seen
spraying Diet Coke directly
into Trump's mouth.
[ Laughter ]
As if all this
wasn't crazy enough,
it now appears that the top
members of the military
have also been exposed
to the virus.
-All but one member
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
are now under quarantine,
this after a top
Coast Guard official
tested positive for coronavirus
after visiting...
the White House.
-This is nuts.
Our top military leaders
are working from home!
Right now,
there's a four-star general
getting really
into sourdough bread.
[ Laughter ]
It's comforting to know that,
if someone were to attack,
our officials will be quickly
trying to figure out
a Zoom link.
[ Laughter ]
Let's change gears here.
I saw that Apple
is now involved
in a pretty interesting lawsuit.
Listen to this.
-Apple is suing a former
recycling partner in Canada
for allegedly not doing its job.
Apple claims
the recycling company
actually resold more
than 100,000 iPhones, iPads,
and Apple Watches that it
was supposed to destroy.
-Apple was like, "Hey!
Reselling the same phone
over and over is our thing."
[ Laughter ]
Apparently,
the recycling company
sold some of the old phones
and then kept the rest
in a random kitchen drawer,
like everyone else.
[ Laughter ]
"This'll be worth
something someday."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
Yesterday, Governor Phil Murphy
tweeted that "Halloween is ON"
in New Jersey this year.
[ Laughing and scoffing ]
Halloween's very special
in New Jersey.
It's the first time parents
get to see their kids
go door-to-door
making "collections."
[ Laughter ]
[ Italian accent ]
This is it?
[ Laughter ]
I'll be back
for the rest tomorrow,
and you better have it.
[ Laughter ]
Check this out.
I read about a man
who paid for a billboard
advertising a date with him
back in January.
And good news --
he now has a girlfriend.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
[ Whistling ]
Though it got weird today
when there was
a giant billboard that said...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a new study
just came out that says...
...and there's no part
of their brain
that can tell the difference
between the front and back
of humans' heads.
[ Laughter ]
-Hm.
-Yes, yes, yes, these are
the scientific breakthroughs
we want right now.
[ Laughter ]